hey this is funny I think some of you
will find this funny hey this is kind of
weird just kidding that's my that's my
traditional segue that they going to as
many of you know my job is to talk about
politics on this show but I rarely
discuss politics on the Internet in the
sense of like arguing back and forth
with people on Twitter and Facebook
because it's pointless I mean that you
can't win nobody wins that stuff over
the weekend
a couple of my Facebook friends posted
political stuff to Facebook and I
decided to participate and it was a huge
mistake
one friend posted a video of Linda
Sarsour one of the women's March leaders
I guess and there was all sorts of
misinformation being touted in the
comments about Linda Sarsour so I posted
my opinion which everybody who watches
the show knows which is that Linda
Sarsour presence is toxic
she is toxic within the women's March
context she's toxic
on the left she needs to be denounced
for her praise of anti-semitic
extremists Louis Farrakhan she's the
opposite of what the Left needs and I
posted that on this Facebook discussion
thread and a mutual friend that I went
to high school with said you are afraid
of Linda Sarsour David because you were
raised to see Muslim women as being weak
and Linda Sarsour isn't weak it's a
baseless allegation to which I responded
well if you're saying I was raised to
believe Muslim women are weak cite
evidence that I believe Muslim women are
weak or that it has anything to do with
my opinion and then silence but I was
very agitated next day another friend
posts about the minimum wage on Facebook
immediately economists so-called
economists come forward saying things
like the minimum wage makes everybody
poor because the total cost of living
goes up more than the minimum wage is
increased and I try to explain no
there's no evidence what you're saying
is that if the minimum wage goes up 5%
that the cost of living goes up more
than 5% for example like for everybody
there's no evidence of that and then
they post a link to debate org which is
literally a list of random people's
opinions and he posts a link to a
Heritage Foundation study which didn't
even defend what it was that he said
another comment about the minimum wage
Pat on this discussion thread this is
why it's bad for me I'm getting agitated
even retelling it someone else posted
people who can't earn a living wage
should be allowed to die as part of some
kind of Darwinian natural natural
selection and when I pressed them he
said that he thinks from my profile
picture that my pants are on too tight
which I think might be even be like a
homophobic comment I couldn't tell this
is why Pat I do my political discussion
and commentary on the show and not on
social media because it was horrible and
I need to never go back arguing politics
on social media total lapse in judgment
poor decision-making poor self-control I
could not be more disappointed in you I
hope that we can maybe chalk this up to
a learning experience because that's the
best that we're gonna get out of this oh
it was a teachable moment for sure and I
I told the posters do not let me
participate in any more of your
political posts or threads because this
is I feel my brain hurt and I felt that
I lost 5 IQ points do you are you ever
involved in those types of Facebook
debates or anything like that yeah so
after the midterm elections here in
Massachusetts we passed a ban on
discriminating against transgender
individuals and a longtime friend of
mine commented on Facebook that this was
going to make it so that grown men are
going to enter women's bathrooms and you
know the the typical allegations that
they're going to sexually assault little
girls and it's all going to be horrible
and I was really tempted to argue with
him to try to debunk his argument
because I knew I could take it down in
15 different ways but I didn't want it
to get I didn't want to get into some
social media war and I did I did stay
off of it yeah I mean what's the UPS
long-term right is like when have
people's opinions been changed by
arguments on facebook that that's kind
of the reality and no matter how good
you think you can explain something what
it turns out is there's a lot of
dunning-kruger people who just lack the
ability to recognize that they're
ill-equipped to even think about the
arguments on multiple sides of these
issues and so I'm opting out and I told
my friends don't let me participate and
it was it was really really bad and I
completely regret that that's how I
spent probably I don't know cumulatively
it was probably 15 minutes of my time
over the weekend a minute here and there
are arguing with people never again this
is where I talk about politics on the
show